Yeah.
I have a confession to make today, to all of you.
Would you still love me if I was disgusting, if I was nasty, if I was gross, dirty, stinky?
Yeah?
You would?
You wouldn't go back on that, right?
You wouldn't change your mind after you hear what I have to say, would you?
No?
Well, then I guess I can say it.
Pin pals?
I shot myself this morning!
I shot myself!
I took a big ol' boopie in my pants!
Okay, so you still love me, right?
Take it back!
Say it!
Say it, say yes!
It doesn't matter the context, I'll tell you the context, but I need you to say yes first.
Okay, okay, good.
Okay, I'll tell you the context!
Oh fuck, no!
That's it, that's the stream.
That's it, I'm done, that's all I have to say for today!
Okay, okay.
I'll tell you the context.
So, you know how I said I was sick yesterday?
Well, today I was just sitting on my computer looking at TikToks to show you for the stream.
And I felt like I needed to fart.
So, you know, as one does when they feel like they need to fart, I farted.
Um, little did I know that it was not truly a fart.
It was going to be a shark.
Ew, ew.
I sharded my pants!
Way more than a little came out, it was so gross, it was so like...
Should I go into the texture?
I don't have a shit kink, I don't have a shit kink.
Don't, I don't have a shit kink, please don't start like thinking that I do, okay?
I'm not into poo poo poo poo, okay?
I'm eating sausage rolls.
I just thought it was a funny story to tell you.
And you would tell me if you shot yourself too, right?
I want you to tell me, I want to hear all of your embarrassing stories.
And I'm also drinking coke.
Right.
No, I don't want pictures of your shit!
No, we're not that close yet, we're not that close yet for you to send me pictures of your poop.
Right, before I start, thank you to the person who got me a drawing tablet because now I can do an art stream.
And I really want to design a 2.0.
Now, I think some people misunderstood me the first time when I said I wanted to make a 2.0.
So let me clarify myself.
What are sausage rolls?
It's sausage with bread inside.
Poop tributes instead of cum tributes?
I mean, I shot on the toilet to the thought of you today.
I love you.
Right.
So, um, uh, uh, uh, uh, yeah.
So I, it's not like I don't like this design.
I think it's really cute, I really like it, but also like, you know, I, as an artist, I'm very picky.
And I want to be emo.
Um, but that doesn't mean I'm going to like unlollify myself, lollify my, unlollify myself.
I'll still look the same.
I'm not going to give myself, myself like giant tits and ass and make myself like five foot seven or anything.
I'm going to look the same mostly.
I just, well, not the same, but like, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Like the character itself will remain the same, you know?
So yeah.
I want to do that next week.
I think that would be really fun.
Yeah, like a hot topic.
We're going to design it next week together.
I really want to.
Could have an opi toggle.
I don't think I'm going to do that.
I don't think people want me to do that.
You know, I'm the special one in this, in this group.
I'm the special one because I'm the only one without boobs.
Okay.
I think that's all I had to say.
Oh, piercings would be really fun.
Oh, now you got me thinking where the piercing could go.
So, so, so, um, no, I'm not turning myself into a furry.
Absolutely not.
So I picked out.
Let me make sure sound is okay.
Should I go to the gaming screen?
Yeah.
If you want to give me scars, that's fine.
Like, um, you can like make a, sorry, I am still sick.
I showed myself this morning.
If you want to do like a Pinterest board or something.
Um, and you can send me the link to it through marshmallow.
That's cool.
Obviously.
Yeah.
I think you can send the link.
Um, go ahead.
Okay.
So RGB boom tattoo.
Maybe I can make it glow.
But apparently, apparently I learned very, very, uh, recently that a womb tattoo that
glows is a womb tattoo that's been, or no, a womb tattoo that glows is a womb that's
been, um, fertilized.
And I didn't know that.
So I feel like, how long should I make by you?
Should I make my womb tattoo glow?
Is that what you want?
Okay.
Um, so how am I going to do this?
I downloaded a bunch of Tik Toks.
It's probably not enough to fill up the whole time, but basically what I want to do here,
well, I'm eating my sausage rolls.
Um, gender bench version of myself.
Um, I don't see why not because it's still me, but also I don't want to, I don't really
want to be gender bent.
I feel like if I'm going to put all this effort into a model, I want to be like me.
With two inch, shut the fuck up about my two inch cock.
It's way bigger than that.
Someone a long time ago, like, head cannon that my dick is two inches long, and now everyone's
just going for it and saying I have a two inch long penis.
It's, and they gave I see a seven inch long penis.
Like what the hell?
That's not fair.
I should be the one with a seven inch long dick.
Two inches is big.
Oh, I'm going to hold my, I'm going to hold your hand when I, when I tell you this, but
it's not.
Okay.
How am I going to do this?
That's not right.
Okay.
Right.
So.
All right.
If you see my full name and address.
Okay.
All right.
If you see my full name and address, please close your eyes.
Oh that's not it.
Okay.
Why does VeeTube studio work?
Why does it say that it's capturing VeeTube studio?
What?
I'll put it over there.
Okay.
Okay, that doesn't work wrong thing
Okay, let's not do that
Oh, there we go there we go
Oh
She's an iPhone or what makes you know what makes you say that
Wait, did you see that I have iPhone connected? Oh, yeah, of course. I have my oh wait now you can see everything
Is there nothing anything sus in there
No, of course I have an iPhone connected. I'm using a freaking model. All right
I'm using a vtuber model. Of course. I have an iPhone. There we go. There it is. Okay, and now the sound we just need sound
This one
Okay, well if I you know accidentally make it too loud, I'm sorry. Yeah, let me turn off the background music
Yeah, thank you for the suggestion. I found his trash. Well, it's good for tracking vtubers. Unfortunately
I
Right
So how this is gonna work is I'm gonna show you a
Tiktok and
I want now these are all my favorite tiktoks from like the past few weeks
I've curated curated my folder here of my favorites. So I want you
I want you to rate them. Yeah
You're the one doing the meme review
Okay
So, yeah, I want you to read every single one
I curated it just for you, right? I think they're funny
Okay, so
Guys seriously, how do I get my roommate's boyfriend to stop serenading her in my presence?
And then they fucking go in for a snuggle. That's okay
That's really all
This is why I'm happy that my mom never forced me to live on campus with a roommate because this is what I imagine it's like
Absolutely no shame
Absolutely no shame just in front of the roommate the poor girl
If I was her I'd be really pissed because I hate seeing happy cobbles in front of me
Okay, next one next one next one. I do work here. Yes, I do. Can I help you you work here? Yes
How may I help you? I'm glad somebody does I'm looking for a kentia palm. Okay, kentia palm specifically
You work at a plant nursery. I'm gonna make a bold assumption that you know what that is kentia palm
Yeah, let me look at our system just so I can see if we have it in stock
Sir sir
Hello, sir, we're still looking. Okay. We're still looking for that kentia palm. We have one in the back
They're putting it in my car right now. Oh, excellent. I'm glad you found me 20 minutes to find it. Oh
20 minutes. Oh, no, I didn't know I was gonna go on a wild goose chase today
But I guess he's making it sound like it's your fault to let you know. Well, sorry about that, sir
Yeah, I just want to let you know. Yeah, really sorry, sir
Sorry you had to go through that. Oh
Hi, sir. Do you need help moving it to your car? There he is
What are you talking about? I deliberately sold me the wrong tree the biggest fucking waste of time. Come on, dad
Please calm down
My son, dad, he'd like to talk to you. Hello, my son. You said a nurse speaker. Hi, sir
I work here at the nursery. I was just trying to tell your dad that we do have a kentia palm
Oh my god, the face. You're still interested in buying it. You hear that dad. They have it. There isn't a problem
Hey, man, I'm really sorry about this. Oh, don't need to apologize. This happens all the time
He looks constipated. Okay. So the only reason I show you this is because I've worked in customer service and this felt very
Relatable to me
Five out of ten
Come on. That was the least of six. That was the least of six. Maybe sharding out
Sharding out of ten. I'm gonna shard on you next time every time I fart. I'm gonna aim it towards you
I'm gonna turn around and aim it towards you and that way if I sure it's gonna be on you
If you've worked customer service, you know how relatable this is okay old people like
They make everything your fault
Basically, oh, this was priced wrong. It was your fault and you need to fix it for me right now
I
Don't think I have any I
Do have like one guy who came in once I used to work at a grocery store. Oh
My god, I used to work at a grocery store
A long time ago as a cashier and this one guy came up to me and he was like
How much are the chicken like the roasted chickens and I was like, I don't know
Like I may be a long time ago when boomers worked that that's like the norm for cashiers to know the prices of everything
But I said, I don't know but you can go look yourself. So he comes back with a chicken. I
Scan it and he's like no no no no no no a couple weeks ago. The chicken was like 699
Why is it 899 now or something like that and I'm in my head. I'm thinking well
I didn't work here a couple weeks ago
So I don't know so I just told him like
I don't know. Do you want me to call a manager?
And he straight up said no, don't call a manager. The chicken should be 699
Anyways in the end, I think he ended up leaving out of anger because he didn't get his chicken
But
I don't I don't like boomers. It's called inflation literally
I carefully peeled off the label on my Cosmo Stanley tumbler
The packaging was so cute. I had to get it laminated
Fucking water top and I rolled it up and tied it with a scrunchie
And heated it with a blow dryer
To tie it with the scrunchie. I added some glue dots to the back
And now I can use my tumbler. I'll give you context on this one. I'm messing up the label. I'll give you context
Okay, I didn't realize this one might require context. So
Basically, do you know those Stanley cups that are really popular?
This tick tock is using the sound of a girl
Who laminated the wrap like the cardboard wrap around her new Stanley cups
So that way she could keep it on the cup like forever
It's like a weird obsession with Stanley cups people people collect like
Like hundreds of them evolve all the colors. Did you know that?
Free lead poisoning. Wait, does it have lead poisoning?
Not what does it have lead poisoning? Does it have lead?
And so this person just made fun of them by using an ocean spray bottle
On my cosmos Stanley and just and just laminated
I had to get it laminated the packaging was so cute. I asked to get it. I have dated and tied it with a scrunchie
Bruh
Not based, huh? Okay
Oi oi oi
Hey snuggle bear. What's taking you so damn long?
Sorry
You damn nerd you could have just called me how would have picked you up already milady
Oh
Yeah, well, I guess I just don't want to disturb you. Yeah, whatever
I'm hunting for new ops right now, but I can wait till tomorrow if you need me to
I can come and get you my sweet sugar plum. Just let me know
Don't worry. I'm fine. I'll protect you with my life my darling kitten whiskers
Let me know if that damn buck an uber driver gives you any trouble
I can take care of him
I know you can't alpha, but please stop thinking about exploding the drive. I'll be the judge of that
You remember what happened the last uber driver, right?
Yeah, it was a pretty grim sight
One thing I'm gonna do it's finish the damn job
Well, anyways princess. I'm gonna keep practicing my lethal explosion technique until you get here
Hold on. I just realized that my I need to change something about the desktop audio hold on
desktop audio
Okay there
10 out of 10 5 out of 10
It's supposed to be cringe on purpose
Okay, my glorious emperor. I'll see you very soon. See you soon snuggle bear
You want me to call you my little kitten whiskers
It's it's one of those cringe like ladies use this if you ever feel unsafe
If you ever feel unsafe in an uber 2 out of 10
What I like this person this person makes really funny bakugo um cringe stuff
It's supposed to be cringe on you on on purpose on purpose zero out of 10
Oh
You don't understand real cringe bruh
The ones who are saying nine out of 10 and 10 out of 10 are valid. Thank you
Do you have a cold?
Okay, go
You know my sister had a baby and I took it over because she passed away
And then the baby left
Lost his legs and its arms
And now it's nothing but a stomp
I
Got a cough
All right context of that one
It's from the movie. Uh, was it called shark tail?
And then the baby lost its legs and now it's nothing but a stomp
More context of this one. How is she even human? Is she they said at the start
She said do you have a cold and then I guess the mom lost her voice from a cold
So she was able to recreate the shrimp voice
You know my sister had a baby my sister had a baby. Okay. I'm glad you like that one. I'm glad you guys like that one
You're hard to please
Okay, this one's funny
I hate myself
I had a wish so much
It would that I was never born
I'm so stupid stupid stupid
Me
Oh my god, that little me in the corner just happy
He's like drawing everything with the surprise face. Oh my god
That's so cute
Relatable out of 10
For sure
Were you guys depressed at 10 years old? I feel like that's kind of young. I feel like not even I was depressed at that age
Literally me
I
Wait, does it say the date 10 years old at 2016 wait in 2016 how old is that?
Wait, how old is 10 years? Oh, I need a calculator
How how old is
Oh, you fucking bitch exposing me using the calculator. Okay, wait, so it's
So it's 20 24
You minus 20 16
So that was
Wait, how do I do the math for this 18 now?
If they were
All right. Yeah, it was 10 years ago. Right. Right. Right. Okay. They're 18 now. Right. Right. Real. Okay. Okay. Okay
Can you believe that I'm graduating from college in a few days because I can't
Okay
Okay, no, no wait not graduating from college not graduating from from retubing
Okay, that's why I might not be funny if you don't know french
I just thought the voice was funny. Yes, he's supposed to cry. Oh, no, what did you say? What the fuck dude step the fuck up
I can really understand what he's saying anyways
Okay, you like that one good good good good good
Yeah, one of those that transcends language. You don't even know you need to know french to understand that it's funny
Next meme
Okay, this is relationship rules
To me
What a kind man me and who I just feel like this is goals for me. This is what I want
It's super cute
Like he literally jumps onto the car
And then falls off the other side just to open the door for her
Yeah, exactly work on your gymnastics
Oh, I'm eating
That reminds me I probably shouldn't have said that I won that gymnastics award
I didn't realize how easy it is to find
My name
um
If you know enough information about me from just me saying that I want a gymnastics award
Oh well
Okay, next next meme cooking for him
Act also a couple goals
Also a couple goals. Look how romantic
He's so supportive
He's so what a supportive boyfriend you would react like that too, right, right?
Yeah, she she um
She puts salt on a spoon
And and just drenched it in a little bit of
Of the soup and fed it to him
Of course it's bad, but it doesn't matter if it's bad you're supposed to react nicely
A hard out of 10 it should be a 10 out of 10
I feel like you're I feel like you're trying to dodge the question by saying hard out of 10
I'm fine with you sharding. I'm not gonna say nothing about your
Bad cooking
But but she she's probably tried so hard
God oh good grief that's horrific
Okay, I just like that one because of the scream at the end
Someone in the comments of this one said um that they sound like Darwin
From from god oh good grief that's horrific
It's such a cute scream. I love it
Not a 10 10. Thank you perfectly good scream. I know
I
I never I didn't miss two crabs. I have I've never heard that in spongebob. Is that a real line?
I don't know
Okay, this one's also a good cut scream
Okay, it wasn't cut but
I don't know what she's trying to do with it
I don't know what she's trying to do with the frog
Make this like
He's so cute five out of 10
She's trying to move it. Is that what she said? Sorry, I know the audio is like really um
I
Don't know
Make this like
It was it sounds like she's gonna say I didn't know that that fucking frogs made this sound or something
That frog is crisp. I think frogs don't really a lot of frogs don't really go ribbit ribbit. They go like they make other noises
That was cute though. I like animal tiktoks. You'll see
All right
This one is also very relatable in this economy
I don't even know if I could afford that much water in this economy
He's really getting fancy with it, you know
Damn even with the lighter
Absolutely fine dive absolute fine dining
Like damn wagyu
I don't know her. I only know I only know this recipe
It looks like he's even using like a mega expensive japanese knife
Now this is my kind of water top this is what I want
I
Tell the 10 10 10. Thank you
Zero out of 10 too pricey. Okay. That's that's understandable. That's understandable understand if some of you um
Puvos can't afford such fine dining
I
Just thought this was funny
I just thought this was funny that's all
You're disturbed
Ah
Me to your toothbrush when I get my hands on that toothbrush you bit I'm deep throwing it like that
Yeah, at least the cats teeth are clean now
She really cares about her own dental health
I
Feel like some people are trolling me by constantly saying one out of ten. I have better taste than just one out of ten
Yeah, ten out of ten. Let him be clean
He's trying to be
You
So this is gonna be me
You want a girl who can cook I I got you I got you
Let me pull out the pop and cook and make some sushi for you
Seven out of ten. This is why this is when Amy makes us lunch. Yep. I'm gonna force feed you my pop and cookin
I don't remember what I got. I might have gotten like burger
A burger one and then I don't remember what the other one was. I didn't get you sushi. Sorry
If you like sushi
Okay, this one's got high ratings eight out of ten. Okay. Okay. Is it eatable? Yes. It's candy. Yeah
Even angels can break
I don't know what this one is from sen. Is it from that dating?
Why is dream here? Wait, that's not dream. Hold on. That's uh, what's his fucking name crud crud
Cryotic, isn't he the one that turned out to be a groomer?
Cryotic yeah, I thought it was dream
Did he get canceled or something? I just thought this was fun. Are they all dressed up as Harry potty Harry potty
Harry Potter characters
Oh god, I just thought this was funny because I related to it especially with the furry character
The furry doodles I used to do all the time. I wish I could find my furry doodles so I could show you
Oh my god, they were they were basically exactly like this. I copied this sort of art style
Anti-septiceye
Ten to ten ten ten, okay, so it was like you guys relate to this one. Were you also trying cringe beauty pie fanner?
in 2016
It was like the tumbler era. Yeah. Yeah
When these two had like their hair colored colored and everyone was shipping them one out of ten. What?
You're lying
For you I was drawing furry art. Yeah
I still draw furry art. I just don't have it on this um profile
They say do these home
Do I have it on this profile? I don't think so. No
No, I don't
Okay, next meme
I'm a racist
I don't hate anybody because what they like. I feel like this is something
Christian
I hate people because of the way they look
I low key feel like this is something
I'm a racist
I don't hate anybody because what they are like
That's not kind or christian
I hate people
Because of the way they look. I knew it. I knew it. I knew you guys. I knew you guys were gonna like that one
Um
Yep
You're right at least he's honest at least he's honest. You're that one friend apparently
I'm not happy customer. I am not happy. Look at this all of these. Yeah, they're chilling. I was at 150
Look at these three workers. I've just decided to have a little nibble
A little nibble. I've just lost three valuable lollies. Three valuable lollies. Oh my mom's life
This was not even me. I don't know why there's three of them and quite a refund either man
There's probably more in there as well
I bought
I amazon prime jeff bezels and that bro. Tell your workers stop having them some little nibbles of my lollipops, bro
Little nibbles of my lollipops. Well, you need to feed you some feed your flipping workers, man. Look at this
All of these are all three three of these man. It's gone to waste because the workers that have a little nibble
push your
I just thought I just thought the axel was funny
I feel like british axel's are really funny to me british l10
Three of your workers have got a little nibble on my lollies
Listen, yeah, listen, yeah, oh my mom's life. This was not even me on my mom's life. This wasn't this was not even me
Listen, yeah
No, I sense
negative three lollies
Okay, that one that one was good that's your head of 10
I'm glad you guys are liking my memes. I thought you weren't gonna like them
Okay, maybe you won't like this one
I
Just I don't know how many of you are into my little pony
Do you know this guy? He's like a huge memer
So 10 a 10 10 out of 10
Zero out of 10
Okay, well the ones that are was that spike in one spike
The ones who are reading a little have obviously not seen my little pony. They don't get it
They went on a side quest in the middle of drying
Chad spike
You've seen that man. Yeah, he's like everywhere. He's the one that said um
He's literally the same guy that that tweeted like i'm at the beach right now. Where are all the babes?
cocky want boing boing
Is that same guy?
10 out of 10. Oh my god. I'm glad you guys liked my little pony memes
I had more to show you but I was worried that not a lot of people have watched my little pony
So maybe they wouldn't get them
All you do is you put it in the center here like this and then
Set a fire to it. Yeah, not always, but most of
His quiet panicking
And
Sorry guys, and I didn't play it when it was this bad
Oh my god
And the entire house is gone
Crap oh no way
And
Yeah
What the hell just happened and
Like two seconds and it's gone. You have got to be kidding me
This is not even funny
Seriously, oh my god
It is funny it is funny. I'm sorry
It's fine just be on it
Read the last thing you can't do that in Minecraft. You don't have saves in Minecraft like that
Fire spread was bad. This was pre alpha
What
Are you calling me a pro-minecrafter or yourself a pro-minecrafter? I am not a pro-minecrafter
Yeah, I thought someone said like oh, I bet Amy didn't actually put together her Minecraft world or her mods
Excuse me. You are not giving me enough credit
I worked very hard putting together all those mods and putting together that entire world. Everything was me
Everything was me
I worked very hard on that
I wanted to have an interesting debut and I I don't know how to do many things and I was inspired by dr
Nova E and how she like went went inside her her own brain. I thought that was really cool and I wanted to do something like that
But I didn't want to like
I know I didn't want to commission anyone to do something like that for me. I thought it would be really complicated
So I just did it myself
You're welcome. You did a very good job. Thank you. Thank you for all the praises. Thank you
Um
No, no, no, I didn't I didn't take the ASMR stream down yesterday
I got taken down by youtube for sexual content. If any of you missed the ASMR stream yesterday and you want to watch it still, um
It's on my twitter
I have a link to it on twitter. Just scroll through and you should find the tweet pretty fast good girl
Oh
Next week what's up kittens today. I'm gonna be filming a get ready with me
Hey, this is so freaking kawaii sugoi
Wait, what was that? Call me chihuahua, call neko
Oh, oh my gosh
I
Like this Bakugo
We're literally twins look at us
I don't even know what he's saying
No, of course, it's not real
You guys are giving this low ratings, but you don't know that this is how I act when I'm alone, you don't you really don't
This is how I act when I'm alone
So if you're giving this a low rating then you're gonna fucking hate meeting me
Zero please make it stop. Have I seen a husband out there? No
I am not a husband. I still act like this. Thank you. Thank you
It's it's funny
Okay, I'll move on to to the next one because it's it's cringe apparently
Okay
I don't understand
I I don't know if this is serious
Oh
I don't know if this is serious or not like I can't tell
He's not even screaming
He's just wheezing now
Yeah
Oh
All right, that was terrible that was torture that was real cringe
He needed to take some local lessons
Okay, so I'm pet sitting this cat and uh Shiloh keep doesn't really like me if I try to go near her
She will kind of like
Yet edge herself away and like leave
However, I did find out
That she will approach me and let me pet her if I'm in a specific cosplay
I cannot believe
I
Still can't believe me cosplaying as gojo works. Look at her. She's making her biscuits on my leg
The purring too relatable
Does pussy run away from you unless you dress up like gojo?
Is that what you mean? That's that's that's what you mean
The tampon gojo video. No
What did they like
Did they like turn a tampon into gojo?
Yeah, it's that easy if girls run away from you all you have to do
It's just dress up as gojo and then they'll just come running towards you
I cannot they'll turn right back around and sit on your lap
She's a gojo sim
You know elon musk, I love this one hasn't cook
Bezos, I love this one. He's not doing laundry
Zuckerberg
He's not mowing his own lawn all these guys
They outsource this stuff that I I do the same now
I have a guy that comes in to sleep with my wife because I don't have the time to be distracted from anything
Which isn't growing revenue. Now, doesn't that make you a cuck?
No, that's just good business anything which isn't making you profit
It's distracting you from how you level up
Listen to them. Yeah
I bet elon musk hires someone to to have sex with his wife too for him. Does he even have a wife?
Sigma out of 10. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. If you want to get on yeah, if you want to get on that alpha grind
If you want to start, you know a drop shipping company
If you want to if you want to get your stonks up all you have to do is just start outsourcing
You know all the all the extra stuff in your life that don't matter
like your wife
Yeah, that's that's the best business advice you're welcome. You came here for memes, but you're really leaving with great life advice
Okay
This is just part this is just part noises
My freaking chair keeps creaking and it sounds like I'm farting
Zero to ten
Look at it pulsating. Oh my god
Like it's jiggling
That's literally how I sound like
Amy this morning
No
Oh my god
Why does that kind of look yummy too? It looks like nice and crispy and like
I don't know it looks edible
Yeah, like s'mores it looks like s'mores kind of hot right
Listen if the sound was it coming out of this random ass cup, maybe it would be a little hot
Maybe it would be a little hot. Yeah, hear hear me out. Hear me out
No
I should you know how I tweeted out if um
If I should uh
Would you guys be weird out if I queefed into the mic?
I'm gonna do that one day
He had a thin face
boldest eyes
His hair was short and brown. I think it's all a blur. I think I got it
Is this the man who attacked you?
What is he blushing? Well, it's skin pigment
Why are his eyes red? That's his charon gone
Okay, the only reason I put this one is because
In my old sketchbook. I literally used to draw stuff like this and I thought it was really funny
Like literally this is this is probably like almost an exact exact replica of my middle school drawings
Three out of ten
It's his charon gone. I don't think they drew the charon gone correctly. That's not how it looks like, right?
I've heard more people pee on twitter in the last few days than the rest of my life combined. I'm just here for the right
I don't gotta do it. I just think it's funny
Hey, it's funny. I think it's funny to pee too, but I felt like
I feel like
No, I want to hold it back and when I wanted to be a prize
You're so skinny the zoomer stuff is actually killing me
It's funny. Not even not even all of this is
You're asking too many fucking questions
What are you the police?
What are you the fucking police get out of my asshole?
Yeah, I have a screenshot of your parents home address. What am I supposed to not?
I'm supposed to not know everything about you dude. I was supposed to not google your fucking grandma's name
Oh found your grandfather's obituary. I did that in 20 minutes or less
Let me finish eating. Hold on
Okay, I'm officially done eating sausage rolls
I did find this one to be relatable
Right wave material
That's wife behavior
That's wife behavior right there
Mm-hmm, if she really likes you, you know if she wanted to she would and I would and I do
Is she eating a meal deal? What do you mean? What what cup?
I
Have a small talk more um stalking
Wish I was that sausage roll you want me to bite on you and chew you and swallow you
But the never a minute no not every girl does this not every girl not every girl only me
All right, what do we got?
This is just terrible what a terrible situation to be in calling
Okay, so we're all you guys should understand this one. Come on. Don't fold my cards. You're terrible
You should get this one. It's it's so bad
It's all the different numbers the terrible cards
Ah
You guys are no fun. Why'd you take your clothes off? Oh, you're playing house rules
Nope, not what that means and this is our house. Oh, so you guys take your clothes
He's getting excited again. Oh, so nobody's taking their clothes off. All right. You're going back in the trunk. I'm sorry
It's just you keep doing it
I I didn't watch this whole thing so when he got excited again
Terrible cards
in house rules
Oh, I thought we were playing house rules. Nope. Not what that means and this is our house
Oh, so you guys take your clothes. Oh, so you're gonna take your clothes off
Okay
It looks like people understand that's good. That's good. That's good. If you don't understand when rats get happy their eyes pop out like that
So, you know, he had good cards
And also he wanted them to take their clothes off
The exit does make it. He's so cute. Oh, look at little guy
Babe, how the fuck else am I gonna know where you are if I didn't put a microchip in you
You're acting crazy right now
I love this. I love this lady. Her name is brinny broski and she just she's really funny and she makes relatable content
But also this is also me. Babe, how the fuck else am I gonna know where you are if I didn't put a microchip in you
You're acting crazy right now
In me out of 10 out of 10 good you refuse the microchip microchip you're acting crazy right now
I'll put a microchip in myself too. It's okay
It'll be fair, okay
My neurolink this you're gonna fucking die. That neurolink is gonna kill you
Microchip shut up. Don't give mercy ideas. We'll both do it. Babe. We'll track you together
Oh god, this is more cringe. It's him the alpha
That's so scary
Oh
I told you to stay away from me that ad stopped me in my fucking tracks. What the react reactor lady
It's just so this is chosen by fate rejected by the elf
I love cringe stuff like this. I love cringe stuff
You refuse the microchip microchip. Oh my god, you refuse the microchip. Oh, oh
Cage for onisun cage for onisun for 1000 years
What do you mean not beating the twilight allegations? This doesn't have anything to do with twilight. Oh my god, his face is fucking
What's crazy is I literally okay
Obviously I find this cringe. This is hella cringe, but I literally read books like this
With the cringe ass neat chosen by the alpha. This is the shit I read
I could probably go in my uh in my um
Bookshelf and probably find some cringe name like that
I'm not even gonna lie
This is terrible though. I hate that. I hate that video
I'm sorry
I'm making fun of myself right now
I'm making fun of myself nothing wrong with a little self bird
Oh
I've never watched teen wolf. No, no, no. Did you guys see the original to this?
Please tell me you have
What what would I read this? This is a 10 out of 10. Are you kidding me? I love making fun of myself
15 out of 10
My 10
You haven't yeah, yeah, no you guys haven't seen the original. Oh shoot. Shoot. Okay. Okay. Let me show you the original
You're not gonna understand the joke then
Okay, I'll show the original to the ones who haven't seen it. So basically
There is a video of I guess an oni-chan
A competition at an anime event
And it's it's pretty cringe. I'm not gonna lie. Is this it?
Oh god. Oh, fuck
I I almost don't want to watch it. It's so cringe
Okay, she's cute she did it well she was confident
Oni-chan
Oh my god
Competition's over. She won
Where is this is he dressed up as steven universe
Ah
I just can't imagine
Oh, he didn't get his he didn't get enough hype
I can't I can't I can't I can't I can't do anymore. I can't oh my god
This hurts. I know
And I know I know it's I'm I'm literally birding myself here
By showing you that and laughing and saying it's cringe
It's okay. I'm I'm cringe. It means turn
I can't I can't not after that not after that give me some time to cool off, please
I really figured you'd end it with your best
Why are we so cringe it's because it's funny it's funny
It means in that video
No, I'm not should have you'll never see me in there. No
This is
And literally moving away from you it's terrifying
Oh my god the art
This is so lame
Unironically, I think they'd work really well together. I think they would really work well together 10 out of 10. Thank you
It's just like pen pals and emmy
I'm twilight though, right? You're not making me more to Kai in this ship, right?
They got like the perfect clips for it too
Someone did put if it's six out of 10 the bisexual lighting right there
They do have the same colors
We
Have this ship even start from the drawing
They show the drawing this drawing this fuck-ass drawing. Oh my god. So terribly me
It looks like something from deviant art. I feel like you would find this on deviant art
I
Yep, yep, yep, I knew it was coming. I know I know. I just thought it was funny. I like Barbie
Mean you can both have it
Thanks, Baca
I thought you're gonna say that's what betas are for
That's what betas are for kachan. Damn right. Who be gargling, bro
Shut up. I'm trying to sleep. No, you know damn well. This is
Wait
Are you aggro what the fuck this are you should that's not snow kachan that's clay
They're so good at the voices right
They're so
You are now enslaved that's gotta be racist
Ha ha ha get the damn arrow out of my head. There is no arrow in your head
Am I going schizophrenic? I keep seeing an arrow. We killed our first black person
We already killed your buddy though. How do you feel about that?
Black bitch shut the hell up dick who I'm going fish. Why the hell did you turn southern? You know, I'm the sexy one
This is gold
There's more stuff like this
There's this dude. I think his name is uh pixel something on tiktok
And he literally live streams as both deku and bakugou
And he like switches between the voices and he's really good at both of them
And they're so funny. I might have included one of his streams here. I don't know
But that was 10 out of 10. I don't care what any of you guys say that was 10 out of 10. Brilliant. Yes
And we cancelled no
I didn't say anything
That's not like wet dog in here. Oh, this one's just cute. What is that? It really smells like wet dog. It's so stinky
Ew it smells like wet dogs. Who's stinky in here?
Oh
This one's just cute
I've seen a guy voice deku while playing cotton. He's so cringe in a funny way. I love it when people do his voice
I love it. I think it's because his voice is so bad
It's so like
Like, oh, uh, you know how I said I was watching I watched two year eternity the dub for that literally sounds like
It literally sounds like deku. Hold on and I couldn't I usually uh confession here. I usually watch
dub the anime
I know I know I know I know I know
boo loser
um
What's his name?
What's the main character's name I forgot
Into your eternity his name is like fushi fushi fushi dub
He sounds exactly like deku and I as soon as I heard the dub for two year eternity. I was like fuck this shit. I'm out
What do you think I should do now do you think no, that's not it was like the first episode. I was like god, that's awful
Okay
Oh
He sounds old there. Okay, whatever. I can't find it. But if you watch the first episode, it's so dekuy. I couldn't handle it. Oh my god
That's gumballs v8 wait really wait gumball voices
No way does he actually
That's worse than shitting your pants
The dub of my hero academia is better than the sub really I haven't watched much of the show
Okay next meme no one has made this dramatic of a change yet. No one has made in my generation this
Extreme of a switch and I am the first in the generation. It is very scary, but
Someone's gotta do it
I just put that one because it's also very relatable. I stopped sleeping in my mom's bed at like
14 years old
It is gumball gumball voices deku
Really
I don't even know deku's like actual name
Deku mhj voice actor
Justin briner
Izuku that's his name izuku midoriya
You're shitting me
No he didn't
Wait who just what yeah 14 I slept in my mom's bed with her until I was 14
That's just in the briner yeah
Now you're confusing me is just in briner gumball
Oh fushi's english b. Oh
Oh
To your eternity fushi b. A
Dub
Jacob hopkins oh that sounds familiar
Jacob hopkins
Oh, you're right. Okay. Okay. Thank you
Regularly or just sometimes oh, I slept like regularly until I was 14
Do you understand why I had to punish you earlier?
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, what what I have to punish you
Because you bit me yeah, yeah, why'd you do that?
Yeah, yeah, are you hungry for your big day today?
I don't know what the original sound of this is from
I just
I just think it's really funny. It's um shining armor and uh
Oh, shit. I forgot her name princess
Cook cook cook cook princess
From the crystal kidding cadence cadence cadence. Yeah, princess cadence and shining
But what I have to punish you I just think the audio is funny
Because because you bit me because you bit me. Yeah. Yeah, why'd you do that?
Bro, look, she's even meowing. Look at that jawline
Yeah, yeah
Are you hungry from your big day today?
Oh
You can see the fire in the background
Is she crying for her mom
It is not me cooking
I've never because it looks like she's just frying the tort the tortilla
on um
You know on the stove like platform itself. Is that something that people do?
No pan yeah, it looks like she's using no pan
So thank you
I feel like that's a recipe for disaster
Like it's literally on fire now
It should be illegal I guess people do it
It's not something that I do but some people are insane like that. Huh my grandmother does it, huh?
Yeah, so this basement apartment gets some fantastic natural lighting over there. Um, don't worry about that
This is the previous tenant the leaving literally sleeping in the bed
To show you the unit when your tenants still in the bed. It's a standard practice now
There's green tape running down the middle. Uh, so you're gonna be getting the right side of the bed and uh, yeah
That's gonna come right off. Um, this isn't a one bed. No one side of the bed. Yeah, so I'm actually moving back into the unit
I'll be sleeping on the left side. So don't worry. You're not gonna be next to anyone weird. It's just me
Oh, I'm john. By the way, great to meet you. Tom. Let me show you the rest of the space
Uh, so this is my mining equipment. It's mine. It's really big mining equipment. Oh my god washroom
You've got the standing shower
You're gonna get the right side of the shower to match the right side of the bed. So there's no confusion
The right side of the toilet right side of the sink and right side of the beer
Any other questions? Sounds fair. How much of this?
Do I have to get married plus utilities? That's a steal right now. What? Why would you?
Well, I guess you're not marrying me. What the hell? Why would you do that?
Is my chat like really behind? I feel like the chat's really behind
Fair deal. What the hell? Okay. I wanted to show this
2000 what did he say?
2,500 bucks. I wanted to show this because um
When I complained about my neighbors and I said I don't have AC people were like, oh wow, she must be really poor
She must live in a shithole
like
Surprisingly
It's like
Really like if you live in Canada like
It is the whole entirety of Canada is a shithole. This is this is like
This is if you've seen like the rental prices like this is literally shit people do for real
They will rent like half a room
And then there's a mattress on the floor there. Well, sorry
There's two mattresses on the floor and you have one half of the room
With you know one mattress and then your roommate lives in the same room with you with the other mattress on the floor
Like Canadian prices are legitimately like that like I got I got lucky
Like I don't I don't I don't live in a shithole
Like I live pretty
Compared to like what a lot of Canadian places look like today. I feel like I'm okay. I'm doing okay
So, yeah, you're lying. What what do you mean I'm lying? No
I mean, I don't know if it's legal, but I've seen like
A lot of people just rent out their basement
And they'll be like, oh, please enter through the garage door. Um, no guests. No music. No smoking. No pets
um
I don't know
400 square feet kitchen is shared bathroom is shared, you know with the with the rest of us. Um
You're only allowed to enter the kitchen from the times of
8 a.m. To 3 p.m
You're only allowed to shower
From, you know, 8 p.m. To 10 p.m.
And then the price will be like three thousand dollars a month. Like that's how bad it is
Mercy's basement is probably kinder. Yeah
Anyways, next meme oh this one's cute
Oh
Yeah, at least mercy's rent free even if you're tied up and stuff, you know
The poor little dog. He looks so old
He was so happy to just sit on the bed with his freaking owner. He just falls really slowly
I hired these two women to cut my grass because I'm all about like supporting women
But they've been working on it for like a week and they're not even halfway finished
Can someone give me an answer on why it's taking so long?
Oh, they're so cute halfway finished. Can someone give me an answer? They're naked. Oh, they're so ugly too
Move to southeast asia. Is that what it that sees look at the exact same accommodations for a tenth of the price
Oh, I know I know
I'm well aware
It's very much a Canadian thing. The rest of the world is not that bad
So, yeah, um, I love skinny pigs
They're so ugly
But they're also really cute at the same time
Shaved they're not shaved they're born like that
But yeah, fuck these ladies taking her money and not cutting her grass
How dare they look at them slacking off. I thought it was a dog. It looks like a tiny pig
Oh my god
Yeah, you know in my free time I like to watch this is anime
This is cool. I just love watching anime. You know, I'm actually 116 Japanese
Oh slice of life shows like the the writing's actually really good and like the drama and everything is
I don't really like to talk to people in the real world
Watching them talk to each other and anime is really entertaining
On the episode where they had to go to math class math class fire
Yeah, I'm gonna just watch like in my free time like I'll watch like one or two episodes a day
Or like, you know every couple days all I fucking do is watch anime. You need to take a shower
How can I watch in the shower? How am I supposed to read subtitles in the shower baka?
I don't need to eat. I don't need to bathe. I don't need to brush my teeth. I like how I lose this anime
Yeah, this one show I watched it's about all these kids are like fall in high school
They have these superpowers though and then in the show they
Like I'm younger as young as possible
Is he wearing two wigs probably it kind of looks like that, huh?
I like this guy he's so funny. I like him young as young as possible. Oh, this is just a big
This is just a video for
10 out of 10 it was very relatable
This is just literally no thoughts in that head
Me shlorp and now in that dick
It's so cute
The freaking bulgy eyes gets me every time
You guys don't know but when I was going through my tiktok likes to like download stuff for this stream
Literally every other
Video was just a rat
Doing something rat content and I had to filter through all of those because I was like I can't just have a full stream of
just rat stuff
Do my eyes bulge when I sleep if I'm happy enough. Yes, the bulge just like that. Isn't that so sexy?
That's what you see when you wake up that's how I'm gonna wake you up
Oh my god, that's so ugly what happens to a child who isn't loved properly
I
Don't play Genshin, but I think the people who do will enjoy that one
You imagine that as fan art if anyone draws here, I would love to see that
You feel called out good. You should what are you doing wasting your life with Genshin?
Bro, I should stop stop stop stop
Okay
I don't know how many Canadians are watching
But this is this is how Canadian geese act
like
Play honkai instead. No, don't play any of them
They're all the same
This is how Canadian geese act
You say what did you say that goose will be dinner? You say that but you've never met you've never met a goose. You really haven't
They are so
They're so mean
They genuinely act like this
I'd rather play with in me. Yeah, don't play Genshin or honkai play with me
Um, but yeah, I have I used to have a bunch at my school campus and like
They were ruthless. You do not get close to those guys. They will chase you. They will chase you
I've literally seen videos
from people that go to my school where they
They like film each other getting chased by geese on campus. It's actually really funny
Oh my god, mom you're gonna love this one
What the hell? I don't know who that is
No, read it. Oh
read it
Who is this guy? Has he been texting you?
He's even texting you. It's a minion. That's just from a movie. Oh, yeah
Just read what it says though. Facebook. No
Log in read what the image says under the minion read it X exercise
Yeah
No, keep going. I just don't understand. I don't know who he's texting me. I'm not getting any of these messages
Because I'm not showing you any text messages. What are you saying? You can tell he's trying not to laugh too
You know what never never mind extra fries. Do you get it? Because exercise is not an extra prize
I know but I just don't know who this is
This is what moms are like for sure every time i'm on my phone around her
She's like, who are you texting? Who are you talking to? Are you texting xyz?
All right, am I a minion? No, do I look like a minion to you?
Amy's showing us her memes you guys rating my memes a zero out of 10
You're too you're too boomer and old to understand apparently
Are you in a chat room?
Are you talking on on my space right now Amy?
So you're telling me if a japanese person talked to you on the phone
They would not know that you were from the united states. No, they probably think I was japanese
I actually speak with a dialect like an accent from the southern part of japan where I grew up. What? That's cool
What does a southern japanese accent sound like corn knee itchy off watashi no namai with josh death
This is what strutty would probably sound like speaking japanese. Go cheese osama. There's no way that's japanese. Like what the f
Knee horn go galley with terry meska
That's probably what she sounds like
I am way cuter than a minion. I'm not a minion
10 out of 10 eat the ducky mouse
Eat the ducky mouse
Gary Buster Holmes was that?
Will terry noscar
Yeah, like he literally sounds like a native southern japanese speaker for sure
Oh, hey yo gozai masu
If an alien abducted me, okay, I relate to this so hard
I love this because this lady like put into words exactly how I feel about alien abductions
If an alien abducted me
Took time out of his day his or her day
To beat me up into a spaceship
Just me not anybody else in neighborhood
I would make love to them back because that means I was chosen special
They didn't just beam up sally next door. No, they chose me because she was out in her yard working
They'd be me up out of my own bed as I'm relaxing playing candy crush. Yeah
So if they took the time to specifically pick me out of all these other humans that are around me
Yes, I'll make love
Unlike these people on tinder
Who the only thing they want to do
Is scam me and catfish me and extort money from me
You never know an alien my all these all these women only want your money. Just go fuck an alien. I fall in love with an alien
And I'm not opposed to that
I'm not opposed to it either
I don't want to get pegged by et
Well, if et loves me enough, I might just let him peg me
Man, we're trying to dissect you. Why are you crying?
Why are you guys saying bogos binted now you're being the zoomer
I
Don't I feel like yeah et got that long finger. I feel like
I feel like aliens could get really freaky
especially if
An alien chose me like
I don't know like he chose me specifically like he chose to to be me. He chose to bogos binted me
Like uh, I'll get freaky with you if you choose me
My standard is a little okay. The exam begins now. Good morning. Yes. I'm fine. Um,
Do you have any pets? Yes, I have a dog called freddy. Do you like dogs?
This is the crying face. He looks like he's gonna cry. I do not have a cat
But I do
Have a horse
His name is molly
Sometimes
She has 46 days. Where do you live?
Perhaps perhaps I live
in a flat
With my sister
And I also have a mum. What are your hobbies?
My freaking eye twitch food is burgers, but I do not like the color blue. Why don't you like the color blue?
It is bad
because it is
Although I eat water
I would like
Cheese, okay. Thank you. The test is over. Goodbye. Hello
Okay
So
I don't relate to this because I've never had like french speaking exams
but I relate to this because I took um
I took eight months of japanese class at school and this is exactly how my speaking exams went
They were all we had a bunch of interviews with the teacher and she would ask us questions like this and I swear to god
This is how I was answering
I have a horse named molly
This is me and my Spanish exams right
They're they also always talk so quickly to you in the exams
Okay, I'm gonna go um, I'm gonna go pee real quick. I'll come right back
I also weigh my face because I'm really sweaty right now
But I will be back in a couple of
Minutes
Oh no
Oh no momentum
How far are we in the videos? I don't know. I'll be right back
You
Why are you guys spamming waterfalls?
I didn't fall to the second. I'm gone for like more than two minutes. You guys are like she fell into the toilet. She's dead
I did not bring any eminid. No, I flushed all my eminid down the toilet
Were you fried chicken or that shut up? I was muted. You didn't hear anything. You did not hear anything
Always did she bring the mic with her?
She got a shard again
I secretly sharded my pants and I just didn't tell you guys and I had to go clean up real quick
It happened again
Who cuts people's air in the middle of the night? I do they call me the midnight barber
Yeah, well that's an infringement of people's liberties. Is it yeah, so don't ever be doing that to me. I do do it to you
What who do you think cuts your hair?
Einstein my air just doesn't grow very fast. What do you think it stays that length naturally?
I'm in there in the night styling away. How dare you do that to me in the night when I'm oblivious
I'll see my best work when you're oblivious
I just thought that was really cute
Because my dog also hates getting her nails cut so I thought this was a good idea too the midnight barber
I
Just imagine the potential for a wave of blue doughnos. What do you mean a wave of blue doughnos?
Ten ten. Thank you. Not as cute as Amy
Thank you for that too
It's still really cute though the midnight barber
Burp too quiet
I don't know some people hate burps and some people love them. So I try not to burp too much
My
She would raise you if you know
Should I sing along with him?
Well, I'm a battle
If she ever does mock me, I'm gonna tell the world she queefs. So she better not mock me
I've been trying to keep my new streak. We've got matters. You heard him say it
She was the one who taught me the good. She said I'll teach you how to edge soon
We were in Ohio when I first moved. She said better. I'm proud of you
I'm a full sigma and she knows it
You can be signature if you
Edge
I'm so bad at singing
Edge Max
Take me to
And keep me awake so you don't get mocked every night drops give it e-raise and I
Ask if she watches aiden ross if she don't then you can tell her goodbye
I was so bad at keeping up with the
Sam Smith if he was good really really
You're hilarious
I almost want to try again to see if I can do it better, but I feel like it's too cringe
Why am I here just to suffer? Yeah, you're here for me to to torture you with my zoomer tiktoks
You didn't have enough for this. I know I know
He did it way better. He had so much worse than me. This guy's singing isn't bad. Isn't bad. It's beautiful
Hello my microphone just randomly disconnected there. Uh
That's weird
It was beautiful
I'm good now. I'm good now
At least I think I'm good now
Testing testing. I did not shart. I didn't mute to shart
God had to mute
He was done with my fucking singing
I'm gonna show what it's supposed to look like
It's so cute too
It's a little phallic shaped
It's a sock
It looks like the inside out sock. Wait, I don't know what you're talking about. What if he sees in the toilet?
I feel like this is what I would make if I ever tried to crochet it's a yellow tear
They really I mean if for a first time it I feel like it's pretty good. It's the banana cards
It's got it's got more personality to it, you know
Okay, show me your little treasure trove. Why is it so cute?
She made like zombie noises and made the freaking unicorn on top eat. This is this is a
This is a little girl with a box full of cicada shells. I think it's cicada shells
Sierra out of 10
Are you talking about this or the
The bee this is a 10 out of 10. Look how cute she's even got her bracelets in there
She's got both both of her bracelets and her cicada shells
Like what a cutie patootie
Oh my god, there's an ant on my desk
This is 10 out of 10. Yeah
Okay, show me your little treasure. She's got personality. She's gonna go far in life
I
Can't get over how she like makes the unicorn chew on the show
I love the mexican people, especially the big girls
Las gorditas. They are so tasty. Ike Rico. They call me el viejo ascaroso
Which is Spanish for the handsome orange man. In fact, the next big beautiful, uh, when I see I'll be grabbing her by the taco
Las gorditas
Thank you dirty test confirmed. No, I just have an ant problem
I'm sure it'll go away soon. I use like ant traps, but I can't tell if it's working or not
Las gorditas, maybe my rats will just eat all the ants
I love the mexican people, especially the big girls las gorditas
They're so tasty. Ike Rico. Ike Rico. It's an AI voice. I'm pretty sure but it's so funny
There's a dirty tip to find the best stuff when you find a really cute item like this vintage top
Make sure there's not poop on
Make sure nobody pooped on
the item
That's it. Just make sure there's no poop
What a great what a great thrifting tip
I would have never I would have never guessed to do that
I could have probably accidentally bought something with poop on it
10 out of 10 tips. Any other dead stuff?
Find the best stuff when you find a really cute item like this vintage top make sure there's not poop on it
Make sure nobody pooped on the item
How did they even get poop so high up on the shirt?
Like when you poop you poop your pants, not your shirt
poop stream
I would I don't watch coco melon you need to try harder if you want to torture me
I would gladly watch coco melon with my little sister. I don't watch coco melon
I watched my little pony though. That's not torture
It defies gravity. Oh, maybe it was tucked in you're right
Explosive
Oh, this one's funny
I didn't see it coming. I didn't see it coming at all. You don't get it
You all are getting the color of your man's tipped paint on your nail
I didn't get it at first. I was like, why why are her nails white and sparkly? I don't get it and then she shut her man
10 out of 10, thank you
Yeah, you got that his even his tip is sparkly
I've never genuinely I've never watched Twilight genuinely
If I were to choose a team, I'd probably choose team edward just because I like vampires more than werewolves, but yeah
He's got that pale sparkly head
Watch along do you guys want to watch along of dwilight? Are you guys interested in watching dwilight?
Wait
Doesn't he know what she's saying
No, you don't want to watch twilight. Okay. Okay. Okay. We won't watch twilight. We won't watch twilight
No, I won't make you do that
I
Love the nose going up and down is so funny so aggressive
I love aggressive little cute things. I'm an aggressive little cute thing
What does anyone know what is a Russian doesn't even know what she's saying
I need you guys to see in here
10 out of 10 9.9. Why are you so suspicious specific about it? You know the nose or the eye
Context to this okay context to this so this is this is some random lady on tiktok that I follow
I followed her because I genuinely thought her singing was good
And I think that probably gives you an idea of how like bad I am at singing
Because I genuinely think this woman is good at singing like I think
Like I can tell the song cover doesn't sound good
um
In other people's ears, but I to me it's like
It's good to me
You're gonna cringe. Oh, this is gonna be bad
Everybody is disapproval
If the heavens ever did see he's the last to mouth pee
Like she's good
Is she not
Do you like this song I like this song, but i'm just saying like she's she's good, right?
Absolutely
It's not bad
I was born sick, but I love it
Take me to church
Oh
She said a minute really peak
She reminds me of Shakira with the way she sings I think this is a full song cover
In the
She sings like Shakira with the shaking of her voice
It makes me uncomfortable just like church 10 out of 10 perfect. Yeah, she's pleading like a
It's not in rhythm
That's a problem. I think it sounds good like
Shakira mugged. Yeah, Shakira who I only know this lady
She has talent keeping
Oh, this is so cute. This is genuinely so cute
Oh, man, this like makes me cry
Because it's so cute. Some of you probably think it's really disgusting and gross and dirty, but the bull
Oh
Like it's so wholesome I can't handle it
It's probably in New York City, you would see this crazy shit in New York like the bull 10 out of 10. Yes. Thank you
I'm your rat
I feel kind of offended when people call me a rat because rats are like ugly to a lot of people
But this is a cute rat
I want to kiss it. I want to kiss it. Look at this distinguished gentleman
Look at the way he is sitting. Yes
Rats have ginormous balls
That's why I didn't want to get male rats because I didn't want their balls like running across my face
While I'm sleeping and stuff
Look at this distinguished gentleman
Look at the way he is sitting. Yes, very
No, he wasn't eating the rat from the other video
No, I didn't want their balls dragging across my face
Is that too much to ask?
Okay, this is funny because when I okay, so if you don't know
Um on tiktok, there's these like, um
What's it called?
There's like these fortune teller women that will randomly appear on your for you page and they'll be like
This video has no hashtags. It was meant to find you and then they'll do like some tarot card pulls to like, I don't know
Tell you your future or tell you like you're going to meet the love of your life in
Five days something like that, right? So this is I got this
I got this specific tiktok like right before we were gonna debut. So I thought it was really funny
Your partner wants to drink your squirt this weekend
Yep
Yeah, you heard me on that one. Um, they have been thinking about this all week
And they're ready for that rain splash, right? Uh, a little bit of a cancer on this one and I am getting a capricorn
Whatever
Anyway, yeah, your partner has been basically so he knew backwards because we have this obama snow here, right?
We're talking about this double edge. He was not wrong. I understand that this might be the means to be drinking that squirt
Yeah, right, maybe that's gonna have like a three to four hours session where they do that, right?
Where we're doing a little bit of a double edge. It's kind of goes both ways
Which is stunning and then of course lastly, I did get the uh beautiful card here that does have a mega drain
so, yeah, there's
I will say uh hydrate maybe get some liquid ivy or something like that because I will say that this is going to be buckets in buckets of
Squirt and I'm gonna resonate all over the place. There's gonna be resonation everywhere and I'm wishing nothing but the best for you guys
This is this is
It was meant to find me. I don't know what these are
I don't know what these numbers are on the screen. They're not hentai codes. Are they?
10 out of 10 bakey
True in real
There's no such thing. Yeah, there's a stuff like this. There's no such thing as a coincidence
This video was meant to find you your partner wants to drink your squirt this week
It can't be hentai. Okay. I don't know what these numbers are. Maybe they're could they be the numbers to the these cards do do pokemon cards have
numbers
Oh, they're fake lucky numbers. Is that what they are?
What are hentai codes? Uh-oh, you're a little bit too innocent to be here. If you don't know that
How many buckets he just said buckets of end buckets I think
Can we can we drink my squirt?
Gladly
Oh, this is the fucking guy. Oh, I love this video so much. Okay, you're not fucking ready
I want us to be together forever
How are we gonna do that?
Oh god, john. God, john. Thank you. Thank you. I can feel you inside of me. Me too, thank you
It feels amazing
Amazing
And you layer those two boys
Gotcha
I've literally been roleplaying like this alone ever since I found this freaking dude. I'll just be alone talking to myself and I'll be like
catch
Oh god, I'm so I'm so sorry
Yes
This is what this is what my sly face is where it's gonna be like
I may have gotten it stuck in the hair. There it is again. Daku. I told you to not aim for my hair
I'm sorry. Gotcha. I was just I was so caught up in the moment
Oh, this stuff is never gonna wash out
You know, kachan, they actually say it's good for your hair and might make it grow longer
Shut up. Daku. That's just a myth
If people see this in my hair, they're gonna know something's up between us. Oh, yeah, you're right
Come on. Help me clean it up. Okay
If I hear kachan whispering into ASMR mic, I'll invert you'll invert, huh?
Wait
I forgot to make my mic mono. Hopefully nothing
Was fucking up, um
The chat's there from made a mistake with the hair. I'm guessing he got slime in his hair probably
Damn Deku you got it all in my hair
I don't know if you relate to this but I've done this now. Okay
I didn't stream my pussy, but I did
At one point I used my phone camera to look at it
And I didn't realize that for some reason it had gone to the instagram camera
Like you know how I'm pretty sure instagram has like a built-in camera
It went to that
And I didn't realize that and then I when I did realize that I was like, holy shit
or maybe
No, I think what happened was I was I wanted to take a picture of my kuchi to like look at it
And and I didn't realize that I used the instagram camera
So I took a picture of it and then when I looked back on my phone. I was like, wait, what's this overlay?
What happened? I took a picture with the instagram camera. I never posted it disgusting where
That's disgusting. What what is this instagram account called? Where can I find this?
So I can make sure to to avoid it
No, I didn't post it. I did not post it
This one's what he did
Is this from the new planet of the apes is that what it's called?
Proof or it didn't happen shut up
Is this from that new movie because I see a lot of these
Yeah, I love this meme format too. I see a lot of this format when there's no sweets in the back of the
Just some I like I was British brick brick top naked bloke
Looks like it don't donation
For $100,000. I'll show my pussy
I remember I remember when I lost my mind
I
Don't take that seriously. I won't actually do that. Don't do that. Don't don't take that seriously
It looks like 11 from stranger things
Ah
It's such a sexy song too
And they were like, let me do this. This is perfect. This is so fitting for this sexy asshole
Chat makes a yeah, if he makes a joke chat makes a promise you really want that that picture, huh?
So
We did the drawing challenge and then we decided to draw this dog. This is mine
Cute cute
Oh my god, you guys are really taking me seriously with the with the the kuchi picture
I see that next to my bed. Yeah, that's literally your sleeper. That's like a sleeper
Assistant
I don't understand. Why did she give it like human nostrils and a human mouth?
She should hang that picture on the wall. No, it's gonna stare at her while she sleeps
It's gonna come out of the picture and like freaking
Sleep paralysis demon her
The next meme wait, that's all the memes. Oh, never mind. There is no next meme. That's all the memes
You might go mute it again, I think it's because I I think it's because I
No, I might go mute it again. I think it's because I keep accidentally kicking the wire
And also my chat broke again
I
Talks check
You need more memes, I'm glad you guys like the brain rot memes. They were really brain rot. I know especially the deku stuff
I just I just think the deku stuff is funny
kachan
Thank you for liking my memes kachan. I really appreciate it
So
Maybe maybe we could do this again kachan shut up baka
Damn idiot
Okay, I'm actually starting to cringe at myself now
Dekeli is the one next time
I can't do ear licking. So I'll just torture you torture you with dekeli is the one
I had the dekeli voice
Don't worry. Don't worry kachan. I don't know how to I feel like if I try too hard, I can't do it
I'm sorry kachan. I won't get it in your hair again. I'm sorry
We need to wear galvanized square steels. That's true. I had it in the thumbnail here
We can we can watch one galvanized square steel video
Oh
Let me find one
I don't know if these are like the actual video or is this some kind of video essay
Sometimes I need to paraphrase
It's easy to make your work clear. Sorry. You're just listening to an ad with me
The galvanized steel and eco-friendly would be near me. Oh, shut up. Don't explain the meme to me. I want to see the meme
Okay, I found one
No, that's not a right thing
Uh this one
Damn baka
Okay, oh shit
Do
You like the way I flick my tongue or not or not
You can ride you can ride my face until you drip and come the new one square meter room in new york
Little john worked hard for 10 years
Saved up two million dollars to buy a house, but it was barely bigger than a square meter
Even his little cat couldn't fit inside his little cat for the cheapest hammock
Ultimately, he couldn't handle the cramped space and had to renovate it
He starts by removing the original windows and replaces them with a galvanized square steel frame
Yeah, forced with horizontal and vertical wells for extra strength
He spends his last bit of pocket money on expansion screws to securely attach it to the wall
A top mounted pull down storage cabinet is installed nearly nearly as much as galvanized
What's galvanized even mean?
All covered with environmentally friendly solid wood boards for durability on top of the wooden boards
He places a folder he's really living on the edge here
Big enough for him and his girlfriend to sleep on together. It's also easy to put away when not needed
He installs window guard. Oh, there we go
Lifting the cover reveals additional storage space for things like suitcases
Well, he's really smart with his with his galvanized square steel. No, not the toilet!
Not the fucking toilet, ew. Okay, back to just chatting
Oh
It's coating on the steel a very thin layer of zinc. Why would I have a thin layer of zinc on me? I'm not galvanized
Okay, well
Thank you for
Here is anyone else streaming? I should probably wait
You can run my face until you're dripping cold
Okay, there's sheebie and there's stroney
Wait, I can do I can do a pull
Can I do a pull? Do I know how to do a pull? Ew. I don't want to hear myself. Plus start a pull. I'm so smart
Sheebie
stroney
Who to raid? Okay, there you go. Start pull. Ow
Uh sheebies
Where's my where's my body? Where's my body? Wait, what?
Wait, huh? Wait
What what wait?
Wait, um
What happened?
Caps
Oh, okay, sorry about that. I mean it didn't mean to scare you. Just a little magic trick that I learned recently
Uh, how do I look at the poor results? Okay
Um
It looks like most of you want to go with uh sheebie, so we'll go with sheebie then
Yeah, youtube studio
God reading is so much shittier on youtube. I'll never stop shitting on youtube
For their shitty streams be direct
Sheebie, okay
Okay, thank you for coming. I'll see you tomorrow. I think tomorrow's another ASMR stream
Just practicing my necromancy just decapitated myself real quick to see if I would survive that
A little test, you know, trying really hard to get you back. All right. You guys wanted an
Oni-chan for me
I haven't practiced that. I haven't even said it once in an audio
Oh oni-chan. Oh that's cringe
I feel like because I can't speak Japanese it sounds it sounds cringe oni oni-chan
I'll stick to big brother. I'm sorry
I'll stick to big brother. I feel like too much of a too much of a cringe weave if I say oni-chan
Maybe if I'm doing like a full-on roleplay I might do it. How about that if I do a full-on like
roleplay stream
Then it wouldn't be as bad because it's it's like fully roleplay and I can immerse myself
You're welcome 10 out of 10 cringe. You're welcome oni-chan
Okay
Um, I'll see you tomorrow with ASMR again. Uh, yeah, bye. Bye
You